february is american heart month
according to the cdc more than 600
000 people die each year due to heart
disease part of the red cross's mission
to raise awareness
includes teaching more people cpr bianca
holman has our story
let's go 1 000 2 1 000 31 000 cpr
keeps blood and oxygen flowing it
dramatically increases the survival in
those who suffer from cardiac arrest
since february is heart health month the
american red cross is encouraging
everyone to take a cpr class
in an emergency situation there are
three basic steps
first call 9-1-1 next chest compressions
to keep blood flowing
finally using an aed cpr classes teach
the in-depth
proper technique to save a life with the
pandemic going on and more and more
people at home
you know we have to remember that
emergencies don't stop so just because
we have a pandemic
doesn't mean that other emergencies like
heart attacks aren't
aren't also happening with coveted
concerns there are trainings for
hands-on cpr where you only use chest
compressions
and not the mouth-to-mouth component for
more information on cpr classes visit
redcross.org
bianca holman 8 news now